c'est une discipline qui en met plein la
vue
[Musique]
le cheerleading sport inclassable venu
tout droit des états unis mêlant gym
danse et acrobatie plusieurs groupes
réalisent des figures des stades dans le
jargon scheer pyramide sow passage au
sol tout est parfaitement synchronisés
et vertigineux c'est un espoir les plus
dangereux de ce qui peut exister et pour
éviter tout ce qui a chuté alors mon
travail beaucoup justement comment
rattraper cette frayeur pour éviter tout
ça donc on travaille vraiment des
techniques d'aller chercher la flyer
quand elle est amenée à tomber et on est
assez assez stricts sur le fait que
voilà nous fire ne peut jamais en
morceaux de son corps sur le sol les
flyers se sont les voltigeurs de
l'équipe comme l'or qui pratique depuis
quatre ans c'est pas facile de se
repérer en l'air franchement il faut se
faire des repères à force de répéter les
éléments en finit par savoir à quel
moment doit tourner à quel moment on
doit regarder des prisonniers si on est
toujours assurée on sait quand on nous
rattrape il faut faire confiance mais
moi c'est ça qui me plaît c'est
l'adrénaline
ok donc on va chercher la fire vraiment
dans les airs limite vous stoppez pour
aller la chercher et amortir ici dans
chaque groupe chacun a donc un rôle bien
défini
sabrina et base l'un des deux porteurs
du dessous cham lui est au poste de back
c'est un peu la colonne vertébrale du
groupe
là certaines techniques en fait vraiment
difficile et il ya des moments je me dis
est-ce que je vais y arriver est ce qu
on encore y arriver est ce que je peux
le faire et il ya ce moment là où je dis
moi je prends confiance en moi même je
prends confiance en mes coéquipiers et à
ce moment ça réussit et puis il ya cette
euphorie générale dès que ça tiens ça
monte ça monte c'est tout de suite c'est
hyper satisfaisant alors bon des fois ça
tombe ça arrive vous l'avez vu mais mais
on se relève et ça nous apprend à
relever les discuter
[Musique]
quatre mille personnes pratiquent
aujourd'hui le cheerleading en france ce
club d'orléans comte lui 60 adhérents et
ses créatrices les jumelles marion et
johanna voit chaque année les demandes
augmenter parce que c'est une technique
est plutôt nouvelle en tout cas afin
qu'il n'y ait pas apparue il ya si
longtemps c'est donc du coup avec eux ce
qu'on peut voir sur les réseaux sociaux
ce qu'on peut voir dans les films aussi
le côté de sa rigueur ça attire beaucoup
et voilà un mélange aussi de plein de
choses de la danse delà des acrobaties
et du public donc c'est quelque chose
qui attire beaucoup le regard et qui
donne envie je pense
mais n'allez pas croire que le
cheerleading n'est qu'une animation de
bord de terrain pour supporter de foot
américain
[Musique]
en juin les explosions d'orléans se
mesureront aux meilleurs de la
discipline lors des championnats
d'europe en allemagne
[Musique]